did you hear that was that your what
Stan I just I heard someone say hello
yeah there's a lot of fish here anybody
literally anybody could have just had a
look here where am I looking
there oh hi I'm dory yeah well we're
your parents
hi it was my family where did you see
them last I forgot I was looking for
something and I okay totally get it
date night I suffer from short-term
memory loss it runs in my family at
least I think it does are they dory
there you are
look out look this our friend now take
it in whatever this place is it's a fish
hospital dude
names Hank I have to find my family
that's a hard one kid yeah I guess
you're stuck here I lost my family that
is so sad you boy dude not a great
swimmer our friend is in there Walsh the
lowing baby you've gotta use your at the
location I feel stupid for babies let me
get that for you she should just pick
two and let's go dad what I'm kidding
I get the feeling they're shifting us
for a reason like something with one big
eye tentacles and snappy things well
that's very specific but something like
somewhere out there is my family I can't
find him on my own I don't want to be
touched sorry that's okay
everybody does it nothing to be ashamed
of I just think you trust Becky that
he's eating a copper just keep swimming
yeah
does this mean you have to say goodbye
to Dory I don't know why I thought I
could do this Dory
you are about to find your parents and
when you do that you'll be huh sea lions
they are natural predators they could
pounce at any moment my don't you are
you oh don't you worry about one thing
their sleep Deutsch there's a lot of
things in her sleep okay hand me the
ratchet wrench I can fix it but Dad what
if she starts sleep swimming again I'm
sure this was a one